[Music]
the noble consciousness thus finds
itself in the judgment confronting the
state power in such a way that the
latter is indeed not yet itself but only
the universal substance it is however
conscious of being the essence of that
substance it's and an absolute content
being so positively related to it adopts
a negative attitude to its own ends
to its particular content and existence
and lets them vanish this consciousness
is the heroism of service the virtue
which sacrifices the single individual
to the universal thereby bringing this
into existence the person one who
voluntarily renounces possessions and
enjoyment and acts as an is effective in
the interests of the ruling power
paragraph 503 is a very short paragraph
but there's there's actually a lot going
on here when we unpack and think through
particularly with examples what is
happening in this dynamic that that has
to do no longer with both sides of
self-consciousness not just with the
noble and the base but but just with the
noble self-consciousness from this point
on for the next several paragraphs we're
going to be looking at the relationship
between the noble consciousness and
state power and Hegel is sort of setting
the stage he is not yet talking in
exactly the same terms as he's going to
use in the in the next few in terms of
alienation but we should read that into
what's going on here so he tells us that
the noble consciousness finds itself in
the judgement confronting the state
power in a certain way so in its
judgment it's earth tile on state power
remember that that the noble
consciousness was engaged in a judgment
about both state power on the one side
and wealth on the other side the base
self consciousness was also engaged in a
judgment a judgment that had very
different polarity to it you could say
what's what's so unique about the noble
consciousness well in a certain sense it
identifies itself with the state power
notice that Hegel is going to say
something very interesting here though
the state power is not it's self
conscious qua state power he's gonna
reaffirm that in the next few paragraphs
as well it's going to have to come to
consciousness and you might say well
wait a second how does that happen how
is the the ruling class or the ruler
himself or herself not aware that
they're actually in charge they are
aware that they're in charge but they're
not aware of themselves qua state power
as a consciousness they understand
themselves as an individual who happens
to be in the spa
state power for the time being what
we're talking about is the development
of some new shape of consciousness and
we're not there yet right now we're
looking at the side of the noble
consciousness so he says the noble
consciousness finds itself confronting
the state power in such a way that the
latter is indeed not yet a self but only
the universal substance and so this
sounds very similar to what we have
talked about in terms of the power of
the community or the power of other
things besides the state throughout this
this entire progress in in spirit in
talking about the previous shapes of
consciousness and also going back into
the reason section as well where we saw
you know familiar terms like virtue
we're going to talk about virtue here we
had virtue and the way of the world but
before that we were talking about
ethical substance in general so we're
still talking about that here as the
universal substance that consciousness
the noble consciousness is attempting to
align and orient itself by and identify
itself with so the noble consciousness
how does it actually do this there's the
one side of the judgment right and you
know we should follow this out because
this is the first thing that he talks
about he says that it is conscious of
being the essence of that substance its
end and absolute content now there's a
little bit ambiguous in a statement
right is it that the noble consciousness
finds itself to be the essence of that
universal substance by making that
judgment by aligning itself with state
power or is it discovering that the
state power not only is the universal
substance but it is also the essence the
thing that matters the Vaes and the
thing that has centrality and in
importance either one of those
interpretations would actually work here
in this probably intentional ambigú
a statement and I put the same here in
parentheses because we want to remember
that what was determinative of the noble
consciousness was finding a kind of
sameness or at like height you know a
similarity a likening of itself to the
state power it wasn't just confronting
the state power as those guys happen to
be in charge it was able to say I buy
into this I find something here now
that's all really in some sense review
of what has been going on here in the
rest of the paragraph we're gonna see
how this determinately takes place and
this is where it gets really interesting
as far as I'm concerned very suggestive
and it might be good to think in terms
of a few examples here so Hegel talks in
terms of finding in the state power the
as we calls it the end and absolute
content right
it's Veck its purpose its goal and
absolute content in halt what would it
what it contains so it finds a purpose
it finds a larger meaning within the
scope of its relationship to the state
now what is its relationship to the
state here's where Hegel puts his finger
right on it it has to do with the
sacrifice of the ends of one's own of
the individual the individual self
consciousness the noble self
consciousness precisely what makes it
Noble is that it sets aside its own ends
and replaces those with a greater end an
end that is one of the entire society or
at least of those governing at the ones
the archive in that unit well the yeah
the are COI the ones who are rule
the ones who are directing the ones who
are determining we could say so he says
it adopts a negative attitude towards
its own ends to its own particular
content and existence it's well we'll
talk about a few other examples but
let's let's do one example right here
think of the military servitude that
takes place when people are saying ok I
am going to let's take an ancient Rome
right I'm going to leave my farm behind
I don't know whether the hired people
that I have watching it are going to
stay faithful to their orders and
exercise some some self-control and some
prudence or I'm going to come back to a
farm that's totally devastated because
as soon as I left
they ran riot I'm going to take that
chance I'm also gonna you know grab my
family arms and go out and March I don't
know if this guy running the show is
actually smart or not because it's his
first set of battles - but he's in
charge so I'm gonna get into my my unit
as I'm supposed to and March out there
with him and we'll fight against the
Samnites or the you know the Volsky or
god forbid the Carthaginians because
they were pretty tough and I'll risk
death I'll endure hardship I'll carry
all this this this stuff around on my
back and sweat and eat terrible food and
probably get you know some dysentery
along the way and so what's going on
there all of these subordination of
one's own particular happiness one's own
security one's own ends the things that
are one's own particular content and
even perhaps existence one decides that
those don't matter as much one takes a
negative attitude towards them that
doesn't mean that they don't exist at
all as a matter of fact it's not really
a sacrifice if what you're sacrificing
doesn't matter to you so they are given
over to the greater end of
the state where the person is finding
him or herself so he says he lets them
vanish this consciousness and here we
get something really interesting his
consciousness Hegel uses two terms here
is the heroism of service hetero ease
muss does denseness right doing what one
ought to do where have we seen this
service coming up before well you know
it goes all the way back to the
master-slave dialectic that was one of
the things that the slave did in fact in
relation to the lord or the master or
whatever you want to call it right the
hair here he talks in terms also of
virtue
this is the virtue which sacrifices the
single individual to the universal now
where have we seen that before that was
part of virtue and the way of the world
and in that section virtue was not
victorious was it the way of the world
turned out to be victorious and virtue
in the modern sense at least turned out
to be a kind of hypocrisy or an
inability to realize these ends what is
going to be the case in this time we'll
have to see remember too that we're
thinking historically about a long
period of history where individuals are
lining themselves in relation to state
power
you know practically the whole Middle
Ages in some respect and going on to the
Renaissance and early modern period - I
would say so he says what happens what
is brought into existence the person one
who voluntarily renounces possessions
that enjoyments and acts and is
effective in the interest of the ruling
power so the we have a movement here
from self-consciousness to being a per
son being a a bearer of virtue of
service an individual who is able to
bring into being not just their own
being but also in a certain respect that
of state powers we're gonna see in the
paragraphs yet to come so this is a
quite important passage we should think
about what ends might be sacrificed I
said we talked about a few examples so
let's think of some other examples what
about the person who doesn't go into
military service but decides that
they're going to give their counsel to
the ruling class and that means moving
away again from their territory to that
where of the central government what
about the person who decides to give
part of their land or perhaps even
doesn't choose necessarily to give it
but as it has it imposed upon them as
taxes but then rises to the occasion and
says you're welcome to it because I
think you're going to do great stuff
with this remember the noble
consciousness is not just it's not just
that nothing has imposed on it it's that
it chooses to see things in a certain
way and that's what makes it noble as
opposed to ignoble
through this process the universal
becomes United with existence in general
just as the merely existent
consciousness through this renunciation
develops into an essential existence
that from which this consciousness
alienates itself in serving the
universal is the consciousness that has
emerged in mere existence but the being
that is a emanated from itself is the in
itself through this development
therefore it wins self-respect
and the respect of others the state
power however which was at first only
the universal and thought the in itself
becomes through this very process the
universal in existence
actual power this it actually is only in
the actual obedience which it gets
through self-consciousness judging the
state power to be the essence and
through the free sacrifice of self
consciousness to it this action which
unites the essence with the self
produces the two-fold actuality the self
it is a true actuality and the state
power is the true which is acknowledged
as such
here in paragraph 504 Hagel as in the
previous paragraph is going to be doing
quite a lot and he's going to finally
explicitly use two very important terms
that he's allowed to sit for a while one
of them is culture it's being translated
here as development but bill dong and
we've been playing around with that this
entire time the other one is alienation
and hi I'm dong which is is what is
happening that was described in the
previous paragraph still happening here
in this paragraph this sacrificed the
the literally making oneself a sacrifice
of old firown' so what does Hagel stasis
through this process what is the process
what we just described the last
paragraph the universal becomes at
United with existence in general that's
a good thing for Hagel right
just as the merely existent
consciousness through this renunciation
develops into an essential existence so
we saw this in the the movement from the
individual to the person through
sacrifice what's going on on the other
side he says the being that is alienated
from itself is the in itself through
this development it wins self-respect
and the respect of others now this term
respect
achtung is an interesting and ambiguous
one because it also means something like
attention pay attention to this so it's
not it doesn't mean respect it does mean
also deference like when you you know
I'm gonna give way to you but it means
attention so what's going on here is the
what we earlier saw in much much earlier
back to the struggle for recognition is
now being carried out through sacrifice
so the the noble consciousness who
behaves as the noble person get
something out of it and they don't just
get something from others they're able
to have that relation to themselves as
well it's a gain for them
what's going on on the other side he
says the state power which at first was
only the universal in thought that's an
interesting thing to say it was only a
universal in thought now becomes an
actual power and a universal in
existence as Hegel says he says this is
it actually is only in the actual
obedience which it gets through
self-consciousness judging the state
power to be the essence so with no
person deciding to render obedience
deciding to exhibit virtue deciding to
engage in sacrifice no real state power
just tyranny just unfreedom just you
know one person exercising a kind of
arbitrary power over another but when
somebody decides that they're going to
they're going to buy in they're going to
treat this as something valid something
real something worthwhile they they
sacrifice their own ends to the ends of
the larger community now we have
something important taking place but it
only takes place because of this
judgment that is made by the individual
person or really by a whole bunch of
individual consciousnesses so he goes on
and he says through the free sacrifice
of self consciousness this happens this
action unites the essence with the self
and it produces a two-fold actuality
this is an advance the self that has a
true actuality and the state power as
the true which is acknowledged as such
so we we move from a point where these
things are sort of figuring out where
they fit in to a perceived truth on both
parts
through this alien ancient however the
state power is not a self-consciousness
that knows itself as state power
it is only its law or it's in itself
that has Authority it has as yet no
particular will for the
self-consciousness that serves the state
power has not as yet renounced its own
pure self and made it the active
principle of the state power it has only
given that power its mere being has only
sacrificed its outer existence to it not
its intrinsic being this
self-consciousness is deemed to be in
conformity with the essence and has
acknowledged on account of what it
intrinsically is in it the others find
their own essence exemplified but not
their own being for self find their
thought or pure consciousness fulfilled
but not their individuality if therefore
possesses Authority and their thoughts
and enjoys honor it is the haughty
vassal who is active on behalf of the
state power insofar as the latter is not
a personal will but an essential will
the vassal who knows himself to be
esteemed only in the honor only in the
essential representation of him and
general opinion now in the gratitude
shown to him by an individuality for he
has not helped this individuality to
gratify as being herself his language
worried to stand in relation to the
state power which has not yet come into
being would take the form of counsel
imparted for the general good
Hegel begins paragraph 505 by talking
again about alienation meaning by this
the alienation of noble
self-consciousness of a part of itself
it's what he's going to call here it's
outer existence its own intentions its
own desires its own needs but but only
in a certain way is he's pointing out
he's talked a lot about how it's you
know sacrificing and and obedient but
really this only goes to a certain
extent and state power is not yet
developed as he says into a self
consciousness that knows itself as state
power so he starts out by talking about
that side he says it's only it's law or
it's in itself that has authority it
doesn't have as yet a particular will
and what we're going to see here is
Hegel is going to make a distinction
between a particular will and an
essential will the particular will we
can associate with a government as he's
going to tell us in the next paragraphs
to come and we don't yet have that but
what we do have is some sort of set of
norms some governing thing right so what
what what's taking shape here is the
development of rulership of what we
might call governance on the other side
he tells us that self consciousness
serving the state power really has not
renounced everything it renounced its
outer existence which would be as he
called it its own content its own
individual vak purpose and goal we could
call that but it found a goal in state
power right to satisfy it but what it
holds on to is its pure self or its
intrinsic being and here Hegel tells us
something really interesting and again
we should you know when we're thinking
about where this fits in historically
everywhere from antiquity through the
Middle Ages into the
early modern period he says that it's
only sacrifices outer existence this
self-consciousness is deemed to be in
conformity with the essence and it is
acknowledged on account of what it
intrinsically is in it the others are
going to find their own essence
exemplified but not their own being for
thought for herself this is going to be
a preoccupation in this passage and in
the passages yet to come where is being
for self there's intrinsic being being
on Zeke where is the being who Zeke
where you can actually reflexively
relate to yourself how do the others who
are looking at this noble deed doer the
sacrifice er the one who stands out how
are they able to see themselves in their
reflected they're not at this point
so they render what Hegel calls honor
because they they grasp the person
through thought he says it possesses
Authority in their thoughts and enjoys
honor it is the haughty vessel who is
active on behalf of state power insofar
as the latter is not a personal will but
an essential will insofar as the state
power is not an individual as individual
telling them what to do but is a
representative of the community of the
state they're a okay with taking their
orders because in the process they gain
something more important they get to
keep their essential self and they get
honor from everybody else and indeed
from the state power but if the state
power were a self-conscious individual
telling them what to do maybe now they
wouldn't be quite so happy about it
because now its subordination to an
individual so the haughty vessel vassal
right he says the vassal knows himself
to be esteemed only in that honor only
in the essential representation
of him in general opinion so even the
vassal is not really experiencing being
for self they they get esteemed for
being that kind of guy but not being
that guy right a great example of this
is you know the Romans had these stories
about famous men vid you know the the
viateur books a love story books right
these are these stories of these these
guys who did great things let you know
ranging from Romulus and Remus all the
way to like you know deck is moves all
the way down to fairly close to the you
know the historical more historical era
and it recounted like battles and and
people who do you know oppose the
Etruscan kings and legislators who
introduced important laws right but in a
certain sense those people don't exist
as people they exist as names they exist
as characters they exist as persons in
that sense they're so nigh rather than
as individuals so that's what's going on
here and Hegel says it's not gratitude
shown by an individuality why because
this person the noble self consciousness
has not helped the has not helped
gratify the has not helped this
individuality to gratify as being
herself and here Hegel says something
that sort of forecast where we're going
he brings up language bracha and he says
that the language that the noble
self-consciousness would use were things
developed as they should be would be
council rat and we're gonna see a very
in-depth discussion of language there's
a few paragraphs from now in paragraph
508 now in paragraph 506 that we're
going to move into we're going to see
what's missing in this lack of counsel
you